et aujourd'hui un classique de chez
classique préparé par les talentueux
franck dobignard et humaines ou novices
alors aujourd'hui nous allons vous
proposer un cocktail sans alcool le
virgin piña colada donc qu'il va être
préparé par e-mail pour cela donc au
niveau des ingrédients il va falloir
déjà de l'ananas donc l'équivalent de
deux tranches d'ananas puisque donc ce
sont pour des verres de 12 centimes it
donc voilà donc deux tranches d'ananas
qui seront coupés en morceaux
ensuite il faudra donc du lait de coco
du jus d'orange du jus d'ananas
des glaçons
donc tous ces ingrédients seront ni dans
un mixeur et pour la décoration nous
avons choisit donc de faire un petit peu
le cousin de la pomme d'amour qui est le
physalis pomme d'amour qui se
ce sera comme ça
voilà et donc nous allons commencer déjà
par givré les verts dont qui mène on va
givré avec un sirop de rome donc savoir
hommes jeunes insiste c'est sans alcool
ans
voilà et ensuite on a un guide bien avec
le sirop la coco râpé sur le bord du
verre voilà pour la décoration des
décorations donc par rapport aux verts
et maintenant nous allons pouvoir passer
donc au cocktail dont qui mène il va
falloir quinze centilitres de jus
d'orange
on va prendre pour ça le doseur donc en
4 centilitres ou de centilitres et
humaine donc va faire le calcul
au niveau du jus d'orange donc de 15 cm
or ce qui concerne le jus d'ananas on va
mettre dedans donc l'équivalent de 900
sites
nous arrivons à neuf et donc on est
moins de jus d'ananas puisque nous
mettons également il est dés d'ananas
qui ont été coupés à savoir l'équivalent
de deux tranches d'ananas donc iman vous
pouvez les mettre dans le mixeur
on va rajouter l'équivalent donc de 906
litres de lait de coco
et on termine donc pas remettre les
glaçons à l'intérieur du mr
[Musique]
ensuite nous allons il sait à peu près
une quinzaine de secondes
au maximum
[Musique]
il n'y aura plus qu'à verser et donc le
fait de venir c'est bien évidemment avec
la consistance de l'ananas donc va
donner une voix sont mus le zoo comme un
rating accolade
[Musique]
on termine un tout petit peu celui ci
voilà il reste donc à décorer le berre
avec une physalis d'amour
ou une brochette de fruits à base
d'ananas de femmes et ben merci à tous
les deux ça m'a l'air absolument divin
qu'en pensez vous